wollen wir nun allerdings zum besten
live act für die heutige folge und zwar
falls ihr irgendwann mal einen
beschissenen tag haben solltet dann
setzt euch einfach eine sonnenbrille
hersteller der nicht mehr einen
bestimmten tag sondern eine beschissene
nacht habe es nun kommt meine lieben
freunde vor einigen tagen kam unter
anderem dieser neuen modi in denen
allerdings soll es heute nicht um ein
tolles super bequem des neuen virgin als
gehen meine lieben freunde sondern ihr
seht es bereits im titel eingeblendet
die dümmsten live hacks schauen wir uns
heute an wie beispielsweise das hier
wenn man einfach kein geld für ein
lesezeichen hat kann man einfach catch
up benutzen ja dann denkt man sich jetzt
vielleicht hey das kann ja nur noch
besser werden wer nutzt den ketchup als
lesezeichen m wer schneidet seine
tennisbälle in zwei hälften damit mehr
in eine box reinpassen ja aber es wird
noch dümmer und zwar kennt das glaube
ich wirklich jedermann hat eine socke an
die ein loch hat und man sieht halt den
zehn nagel dadurch was kann man dagegen
tun richtig den c einfach schwarz
anmalen und dann sieht man das loch
nicht mehr also das ist sie ab wirklich
ich hörte und ja da wird schon wieder
fleißig applaudiert hier im publikum
warum allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten dummen live act und zwar was
macht man wenn man dreckiges geschirr in
der spüle hat
naja entweder man wäscht es halt ab und
dann ist es sauber oder aber legt
einfach ein bild von der sauberen spüle
über das regiedebut stinkt ja dann ist
wirklich gut 10.000 und wisst ihr was
auch iq 10.000 ist meine lieben freunde
wenn man popcorn hat und am pc sitzt
aber dann einfach den pulli fallschirm
anzieht so dass man das popcorn direkt
aus der kapuze essen kann also das ist
ja wahnsinn der nächste live ist für
alle leute relevant die morgens immer
eine menge stress haben also sehr wenig
zeit haben und zwar kann man einfach
zahnpasta auf seinen frühstück schmieren
so kombiniert man nämlich essen und
zähneputzen
aber ich würde sagen wir machen direkt
mit dem nächsten live act der auch etwas
mit essen zu tun hat und zwar kann man
so einfach sein pizzastück erwärmen wenn
man gerade keinen ofen oder mikrowelle
parat hat einfach ein bügeleisen nehmen
unter die pizza da drauf legen und
erhöhen so dass das pizzastück haid warm
wird oder man macht es halt so wenn man
ein sandwich in der uni hat was noch
kalt ist
legt man es einfach zwischen zwei laptop
akkus und ich schwöre euch mittlerweile
bei den neuen laptops gibt das her
glaube ich gar nicht mehr so richtig
dass da so ein richtiges teil dazwischen
hängt die teile werden so unfassbar heiß
alter das ist eigentlich gar nicht mal
so dumm der live-act machen allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten live act
die hier gerade schon eingeblendet uns
war es ist ein mega cooler
flachbildschirm
das war allerdings nicht immer ein
flachbildschirm denn auf der rückseite
sieht das ganze so mappus
[Musik]
das ist ein low budget flachbildschirm
quasi und wo wir gerade schon bei
bildschirmen sind meine lieben freunde
ich glaube ich jeder hat schon mal die
situation dass die eltern zu einem
meinte hey warum sind wir hier drinnen
vor deinem computer oder vor der
playstation am zocken jedoch nach
draußen und ich glaube auch wenn man
arbeitet denkt man sich häufiger mal hey
ich sitze gerade hier drin und muss
arbeiten und draußen ist so schönes
wetter
man kann das ganz einfach so machen ja
ich glaub da brauche ich gar nichts mehr
zu sagen der nächste live r dreht sich
um die wiederverwertung von kinderpuppen
also von so baby born puppen et cetera
und zwar brauchen wir die nicht einfach
wegschmeißen oder keine ahnung was wenn
man kann sie wieder verwerten und zwar
kann man einfach den kopf nehmen
alles was da drin ist raus packen und es
so hinstellen und es ist auch eine super
lampe für kinder wenn man beispielsweise
einfach eine led der rhein schraubt ja
die kinder werden sich mega freuen
darüber und bestimmt auch gar keine
angst bekommen wirkt es euch auch so
unfassbar dollar auf das wenn ihr euch
irgendwas kochen wollte sie erst mal so
ein paar minuten warten müssen bis das
wasser überhaupt anfängt zu kochen
ich habe eine idee für euch und zwar
könnt ihr einfach wasser vorkochen und
das dann in den gefrierschrank packen so
das ist halt länger haltbar ist wirklich
wahnsinnig war nicht so viel zeit dass
jetzt auch ein starker live act also
wenn ihr so einen plastikdeckel übrig
habt von einem getränk könnt ihr einfach
euer orangen darauf platzieren weil ich
meine wer präsentiert nicht gern seine
orangen ich kann mich gar nicht ernst
nicht mit den deutschen fehlt hier den
ganzen winter hatten live hacks aber gut
ich würde sagen wir waren direkt weiter
mit dem nächsten besteuerten live
hacking soll falls sie kein geld habt
für einen feuermelder könnte auch
einfach eine packung popcorn
und 7 und wenn ihr hier
wenn ihr dann beispielsweise gerade oben
seid oder im keller oder keine ahnung wo
hört auf einmal dass ganz viele popcorn
poppen dann wisst ihr hey die küche wo
es ist so blöd was auch blöd ist der
nächste live act jeder live heute ist es
irgendwie blöd aber falls ihr keine
spaghetti bakugan mehr habt oder keine
coole aufbewahrungs glasbox wo man die
spaghetti dings reinstellen kann ich
spaghetti nudeln dann könnt ihr auch
einfach eine schlange neben ich weiß
nicht ob nur ich sondern humor hat und
über so etwas lachen kann allerdings
würde ich sagen und machen die
entwickler mit dem nächsten live weg und
zwar wenn euer auto irgendwelche
komische geräusche von sich gibt wenn
der motor irgendwie dumm auf gold oder
wenn irgendwelche alarmsignale ertönen
dann macht ein webradio und konnten
beruhigt sich leicht wir machen weiter
mit dem nächsten live ex-freundin und
zwar könnt ihr so euren bagel
stabilisieren dem durchschneiden wollte
dann habt ihr auch noch automatisch rote
soße und bisschen fleisch das video hier
kann ich eigentlich gar nicht allerdings
meine lieben freunde wieder weg zu
wissen ist hier wieder komplett seriös
und professionell unterwegs der nächste
live werk handelt davon dass wenn ihr
beispielsweise einen beschissenen tag
habt dann habe ich hier einen tipp für
euch beziehen sie den live act setzt
sich einfach eine sonnenbrille auf dann
habt ihr kein beschützende tag mehr
sondern eine beschissene nachts und
seine lieben freunde
falls sie irgendwann mal allein sein
sollte oder euch allein fühlen sollte
nehmt euch einfach einen handschuh und
filtert warmes wasser rein und umarmt
diesen mit eurer hand dann fühlt ihr
euch definitiv nicht mehr allein
ja wer sich die scheiße ausdenken
da musst du da musste schon ziemlich
allein sein allerdings ist das hier der
nächste live act meine lieben freunde
und zwar wenn euch euer handy bildschirm
zu klein ist könnte jetzt einfach in ein
glas wasser stellen und das vergrößerte
den spin um bis zu 20 prozent
es hört sich an wie der apple
präsentation alter so krass wie ich das
hier über bringe allerdings will ich
sagen machen wir direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten live act verliehene gar keine
zeit meine lieben freunde weil ich habe
diesmal wirklich echt ne menge live
hacks rausgesucht
das bild kennt glaube ich jeder mann hat
seine küche voll mit dreckigen geschirr
der live-act gerade handelt allerdings
nicht davon dass man sich dann seine
saubere spiele irgendwie ausdrückt und
das darauf legt sondern ihr nehmt
einfach sauberes geschirr und stellt es
in diese geschirr ein dass wenn gäste
kommen die denken hey der arbeitet
gerade schon daran aber eigentlich tut
ihr das gar nicht also das ist auch ein
sehr guter live act was allerdings auch
ein sehr guter live act ist es dass hier
was wir gerade schon eingeblendet und
zwar bekommt ihr so kein ticket
ihr bekommt so keinen ordnungsamt
verfahren dingsbums knöllchen die auch
immer das heißt weil die können's ja nix
drunter klemmen wenn eure
scheibenwischer einfach hoch steht und
der nächste live er hat auch etwas mit
autos zu tun und zwar wenn euer
reifenprofil abgefahren ist gar kein
problem
kauft euch einfach in erding ist viel
günstiger als neureifen können einfach
aufmalen und geht doch viel schneller
als ein reifen wechseln also da wurden
lediglich 37 liegen mit 420 klappen
geschlagen und wo das ganze auch der
fall ist meine lieben freunde ist dabei
wenn ihr beispielsweise x 111 ii machen
wollt mit einem free handy surf stick
als sie macht 111 ii ohne eure hände
das funktioniert nämlich so
ja das sieht wirklich wundervoll aus
foto kommen wir nun allerdings zu den
fünf letzten live acts wie fürs heutige
video vorbereitet habe und ich würde
sagen die rate ich einfach mal erzählt
zum ende durch und zwar ist das hier der
erste live act wenn ihr wieder mal nicht
euer geschirr gespült habt könnt ihr
einfach eine paprika benutzen und dort
raus euren tee trinken
das hier ist der viertletzte live heck
wenn ihr im restaurant beispielsweise 17
dollar und 47 cent bezahlen was könnt
ihr einfach als tipp draufschreiben - 17
dollar und 47 cent bezahlt die nämlich
gar nichts das hier ist der drittletzte
live-act ihr fragt euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich hey warum ist hier so
eine heckenschere am start naja wenn ihr
normaler apple kopfhörer habt könnt ihr
diese schere benutzen um daraus einfach
airport zu bekommen das hier ist auch
ein sehr guter live act und zwar wenn
ihr einen plastik cup habt könnt ihr
dort einfach eine stange von abschneiden
dann könnt ihr den plastikbecher
erhalten nach ein paar sekunden doch
wahrscheinlich kein trinken mehr drin
aber zumindest könnt ihr dem
plastikbecher gut halten und das hier
ist der letzte live act meine lieben
freunde wenn ihr nur noch ein bisschen o
saft habt könnt ihr einfach die flasche
kippen beziehungsweise das tetra pak
kippen und dann seht ihr schon auf der
rechten seite habt ihr auf einmal wieder
eine volle flasche saft und damit durch
das heutige video zu beenden wenn ihr
euch gefallen aber einer lieben freundin
der last auf jeden fall einen daumen
hoch unter dem video hier da schreib mir
gerne unten in die kommentare was eure
meinung nach der dümmste dieser live
hacks war schreibt mir auch hermann in
die kommentare weil ich habe noch
hunderte mehr von dir einen solchen live
acts gefunden
ob ich im nächsten video die mal selbst
ausprobieren soll könnt ihr mir auch
gern mal sagen wie zu beginn schon
gesagt dieser wurde hier der existiert
seit er existiert seitdem gibt es seit
ein paar tagen luca - shop.de das ist
ein neuer smiley hier unten steht wenn
man mal ganz nah dran so kann man
eventuell durch den den bürgern deinen
kopf so wäre dass dieses dorf steht da
also schaut gerne luca shop vorbei da
gibt es auch noch ganz viele andere
produkte abonniert meinen kanalfest doch
kein teil von lukas ist auf jeden fall
super entscheidung und jetzt kommts auto
[Musik]